dans les cinq ans à venir moi je ne
propose pas de décaler l'âge de départ à
la retraite ces mêmes macro qui nous a
mis dans le pétrin c'est populaire et a
mis dans le pétrin il a dit hein je ne
toucherai pas ou 62 ans et là on nous
refourgue l'âge pivot à les français
comprennent pas et les syndicats non
plus et je les comprends
l'essentiel pour moi c'est que cette
réforme est les lieux elle aura lieu
parce qu on a un engagement de campagne
du président de la république à ce stade
citez moi un seul engagement de campagne
du président de la république qui n'a
pas été tenue par cette réforme elle
aura lieu évidemment les gens il est
clair que il allait falloir travailler
plus moi je pense qu'une réforme des
retraites est nécessaire et donc moi je
souhaite qu'on puisse aller au bout de
cette réforme pour mort doit payer nos
dettes et on doit surtout bâtir un
modèle durable pour nos enfants et donc
je souhaite que nous puissions financé à
travers la réforme des retraites notre
poulain note de la protection sociale
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui parce que nous vivons plus longtemps
il nous faudra travailler plus longtemps
et partir à la retraite plus tard la
réforme des retraites alors un lieu dit
vous ce que vous la ferez avant la
présidentielle parce que je dis
justement c'est qu'elle aura lieu et que
la question c'est quand il ya une
décision à prendre notre système de
retraite par répartition n'est pas
financée sur le moyen et sur le long
terme les conditions ne sont pas réunies
pour relancer aujourd'hui ce chantier
pour autant notre volonté de sauver
notre modèle par répartition et d'en
corriger des inégalités n'a pas changé
et dès 2022 il faudra pour préserver les
pensions de nos retraités et la
solidarité entre nos générations prendre
des décisions claires
elles feront légitimement l'objet de
débats démocratiques l'indispensable
mais elles devront suivre à mes yeux des
principes simples
travailler plus longtemps en repoussant
l'âge légal
[Musique]
la première concerne la dégradation des
perspectives financières du système de
retraite à l'horizon 2021 le solde des
régimes de base et du fonds de
solidarité vieillesse se dégradent
spectaculairement le comité de suivi des
retraites le csr pour la première fois
depuis sa création a recommandé au
gouvernement de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour ramener ce système de
retraite sur une trajectoire déquilibre
aucune mesure dans ce plfss ne répond à
l'enjeu financier est bien une réforme
avec le point au bout si vous n'avez pas
un équilibre financier c'est une
catastrophe vous appauvrissez les
retraités de demain je rappelle que
quand françois mitterrand arrive au
pouvoir en 81 il descend de 65 ans l'âge
légal de départ à 60 ans à ce moment là
y'a une espérance de vie de 74 ans
l'espérance de vie aujourd'hui elle est
entre 82 et 83 cents
[Musique]
rappeler simplement que l'âge légal des
pays européens c'est 64 ans minimum quoi
64 ans minimum ils ont trouvé des
solutions on n'est pas plus dans ce pays
mal traités que dans d'autres pays
européens voisins donc je pense que
véritablement doit trouver des solutions
quelles que soient les prévisions
alarmistes ou palerme istres on n'arrive
pas équilibré et non seulement n'arrive
pas équilibrée et c'est que les pensions
diminue on c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est en toute responsabilité que nous
avons proposé cet amendement je réitère
une fois encore en dépit de la constance
de monsieur savary d'année en année
c'est un avis défavorable